thank you for joining us i'm john  langler the raiders make history after a  troubled first two years in las vegas  including criminal charges coach firings  and internal turmoil the team has broken  new ground today for the first time a  black woman will lead an nfl franchise  sources tell 8 news now sandra douglas  morgan is the raiders new president she  joins the silver and black after a long  history of service here in nevada  douglas morgan's the former gaming  control board chair city of north las  vegas attorney she sat on the nevada  athletic commission and currently serves  on the caesars entertainment board team  sources say she was introduced to the  staff this morning a press conference is  scheduled for about an hour from now  we'll have live coverage of that and  have more on this story on 8 news now at  4 o'clock